all right let's get right into audience
questions for the week
really good questions this week first
one david should naturalized american
citizens be allowed to run for president
and be president in the united states
i think the answer is obviously yes you
know the origin of
banning naturalized immigrants from
running for president
was really based around the idea of some
kind of
subterfuge of a traitorous or disloyal
individual becoming president
and really being loyal to some other
country
uh etc and the the practical reality is
that
in the modern day there's no reason to
believe
number one that we wouldn't uh determine
um that there would be a problem with
someone's loyalties
through the course of a presidential
campaign because it is so invasive and
so extensive and goes on for such a
period of time
number two the reality is that the
country
is based on immigrants who came here
because they wanted something different
than what was going on in england and in
other places
and to say that if you've gone through
the process
you've come here legally you've obtained
permanent residency you then qualify for
citizenship and you are now a citizen
to say well yeah you're a citizen but
you can't run for president it is in a
sense creating a second tier
of citizenship now you could make the
case
and i might be swayed by it that
naturalized citizens should be allowed
to be president
but they must be citizens for a period
of time before they can be sworn in as
president so if you became
a citizen today maybe some number of
years have to go by i think that's a
good question i'd be
open to being convinced of that as an
additional
requirement but the truth is that
many of the immigrants that are
naturalized in the us
by more decent and sensible standards of
what we really should aspire to mean by
patriotism
many immigrants are far more patriotic
in in a way that
the term makes sense than americans who
just happen to be born in the united
states
further actually passing the citizenship
test
already confers more of an understanding
of how the u.s is supposed to work
than many natural-born american citizens
have
so i think that it should be changed
it's not for me i don't plan to run for
president
uh even if it's changed i'm not
interested in running for president and
i know
many will write to me and they'll say
david of course you want it changed
it's what's preventing you from running
for president i have no plan in uh to
to run for president but uh consider the
history of this country
understand the basis on which this
country was formed
uh and realize that the sort of two
tiers of citizenship really don't
make sense and um the the arguments that
i continue to hear
against naturalized citizens being able
to be president
uh leverage and depend on fear-mongering
they defend depend on nationalistic
rhetoric
they depend often on xenophobic ideas
they want to stoke
fear but most people understand
that immigrants to the united states who
go through the process of becoming
citizens are
by the definition of patriotism we
should aspire to
just as patriotic as anybody else and
really do want what's best for the
country now
just one other reminder just because
naturalized immigrants could be allowed
to be president
doesn't mean they would win in a huge
part of this country
a naturalized citizen even if allowed to
run
would have no shot whatsoever because of
all the things i just mentioned how it
would be used to stoke fear and
leverage nationalism and on and on and
on so
let them run let them be president if
they win
legally i still think you would see a
huge uphill battle
in many parts of the united states like
many people i know
i've struggled with issues like eye
strain
from looking at a computer screen for
many hours of the day my work involves
working with a computer
and there are studies that suggest that
the blue light from screens
can cause headaches or cause you to
strain your eyes or even cause trouble
sleeping at night
but i haven't had any of those problems
since i picked up a pair of blue blocks
glasses which filter out that blue light
that comes from the computer screen from
the phone screen from the tv screen
so i was really excited when they became
a sponsor blue blocks
is a company you can trust because their
glasses
were developed in actual optics
laboratories unlike a lot of the cheap
knockoff mass-produced stuff
and because my blue blocks glasses are
blocking out that blue light
i'm not getting the eye strain i'm not
getting the headaches i'm falling asleep
easier at night and that's the whole
point of this thing it's been a real
game changer
they have 40 different frames to choose
from there's even a prescription version
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
and you'll get 20 percent off everything
in their store
plus free shipping worldwide on orders
over a hundred and fifteen dollars